as the mainstream media continued to
provide cover and propaganda for
Palestinian terrorists another nation
Guatemala has followed American moral
leadership and moved its embassy in
Israel to Jerusalem we will analyze why
president Trump's embassy move has so
infuriated Democrats and the mainstream
media this is about much much more than
just Israel spoiler alert then we will
speak to an actual Jerusalem resident
your Amazon II doctor your Amazon II
about his forthcoming book the virtue of
nationalism and why conservative and
classical liberal don't actually mean
the same thing even though everybody
says they do finally on this day in
history
amid little rocket man's idle threats we
analyze how past presidents have handled
communist dictators and collapsing peace
talks
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
you can probably hear in my voice I'm
still sick and tired of winning all of
the winning of the past two weeks has
kept me literally sick and tired and
probably given me a sinus infection but
that's okay
nevertheless I persisted so we're gonna
keep trucking on this morning I had the
great pleasure by the way of attending
Mira Costa high school to give a speech
about gun rights why conservatives
support the Second Amendment what the
Second Amendment means and why we need
to protect it I'm gonna be streaming
this from The Daily wire we're not quite
sure when it's gonna go up we're gonna
try to stream it either later today or
tomorrow be sure to look out for this I
have got to tell you these kids were so
smart first of all it was incredibly
courageous of the faculty and the staff
and the student groups there in the
administration to have a speaker come in
and defend gun rights at a high school
this was brought to us by the Yap
organization at this high school all of
the students were incredibly smart
incredibly sophisticated both the
Democrats and the Republicans
there was no crazy protest there was no
shouting just really thoughtful students
on both sides I go to these schools and
they make me worried about the future of
America because of all these yelling
protester types then I go to this high
school Mira coast and I think oh man the
future is bright this is pretty good
really really sophisticated students so
but we'll have that out for you is a
really fun time good talk good questions
so look out for that before we get into
nationalism this is gonna be a really
good topic today because the media
they're screaming the Democrats are all
arguing but they're not getting to the
actual problem they have which is
nationalism we're gonna discuss with an
expert before we do that we got to thank
honey we got to thank honey a wonderful
sponsor helps keep the lights on I just
used honey I use honey all the time but
I just used it like two days ago when I
was making a purchase and it's the best
it just saves you money millions of
people are using honey to save money
while shopping online
why wouldn't they it's free it takes
just two clicks to add to your browser
saves you tons of money it is this
ingenious add-on one of my absolute
favorite things about honey is how much
better it makes shopping on Amazon so
honey will just you just add it to your
browser it's free it will add all sorts
of useful info right onto the
Amazon page of whatever you're looking
at so jus just shop like you normally do
honey automatically searches the 2
million sellers on Amazon finds you the
lowest price it shows you items price
changes in case you want to wait and
decide to buy if you decide to wait a
honey drop list will let you know if the
price drops honey's got your back you'll
never overpay for anything on Amazon
again honey has saved me personally so
much money in the last few years you
would be out of your mind not to add it
to your browser there is no reason not
to add honey of your browser today it's
free it takes just two clicks to install
it will make sure that you will always
get the lowest price on Amazon and other
places as well add it free right now
join honey calm slash cough FA Co V of
EF e join honey calm slash cough fa c OV
e fe fe very very cough f ab & OD'ing on
cough a fillet recently that's why you
can hear it in my nose but it's been too
good not to the mainstream media are
absolutely furious about president
Trump's relocating the American Embassy
in Israel to the capital of Israel here
is just a quick rundown a quick supercut
of all of them reporting on that embassy
opening from CNN Fox Washington Post The
New York Times here it is Donald J Trump
is now President of the United States
[Applause]
remember to be able to introduce for the
first time ever anywhere that 45th
President of the United States of
America Donald
[Music]
there is no one if that was Jim Acosta
at the end I think there's really
basically sums up their response they're
so upset and it it is a really bizarre
when you think about it because the
mainstream media should not have been
caught by surprise by this every
president of the United States
practically every presidential candidate
over the last several decades and
certainly every president has promised
to do exactly this to widespread
applause in both parties in case anybody
forgot here's just a quick montage of
every president promising to do this
Jerusalem is still the capital of Israel
and must remain an undivided City
accessible at all as soon as I take
office I will begin the process of
moving the United States ambassador to
the city Israel as children as his
capital I continue to say that Jerusalem
will be the capital of Israel and I have
said that before and I will say it again
Jerusalem will remain the capital of
Israel and it must remain undivided we
will move the American Embassy to the
Eternals capital of the Jewish people
Jerusalem
[Applause]
therefore I have determined that it is
time to officially recognize Jerusalem
as the capital of Israel while previous
presidents have made this a major
campaign promise they failed to deliver
could you could you spot the difference
but we have between all those guys
clinton promises at Bush promises Obama
promises they all promise then from
promises and actually doesn't it's not
like the mainstream media haven't heard
this before they just didn't believe it
because in the old days politicians
would just say certain things and we
knew they didn't really mean it never
and they knew that we knew that they
didn't really mean it but it's just kind
of political talk then Trump says he's
gonna do something and he does it and
everybody loses their minds so why are
the mainstream media so angry about this
Ben had an excellent piece on this up
today
he's absolutely right it's because
Jerusalem is a pillar of the West what
this says is that Jerusalem is a pillar
of the West the West is made by
Jerusalem and Athens revelation and
Greek reason and they come together and
they form the West and what president
Trump's moving the embassy there has
said is the capital of Israel is
Jerusalem this is a pillar of the West
it's going to remain that way it's not
an eastern city it doesn't belong to
various Arab groups that want to claim
Jerusalem it belongs to Israel it
belongs to the West they can't handle
this the mainstream media despises
Israel they despise Israel because they
despise the West and they despise the
West because they despise themselves
this is an essential aspect of the left
this self-hatred manifests as a hatred
of their of their own culture of their
own institutions of their own religious
longings and of their own God it comes
out in all of those ways the second
reason that the mainstream media is so
angry about this is because of
nationalism because this is a
manifestation of true nationalism what
Donald Trump is saying is that Jerusalem
is part of Israel and therefore it is
not part of the country of Palestine the
country of Palestine by the way we
talked about this on the conversation
yesterday the country of Palestine is to
the west of wakandan to the east of
gnarnia if you're trying to locate it on
a map anywhere but what there
is that the Jerusalem this city is in
this country it's not in another country
deal with it
countries have borders the Westphalian
system of nation-states still exists it
still defines the world order and we're
going to keep it that way this is a huge
affront to the mainstream media's
project of erasing national boundaries
of blurring national distinctions and
having just you know peace and love and
hippie-dippy man that they that this is
an affront to that because we're saying
no the nation-state still exists still
has capitals there was a Washington Post
op-ed about this by Kathleen Parker
this is how they Kathleen Parker
reported this quote Monday started the
week with a jolt in Jerusalem where the
United States and Israel celebrated the
u.s. embassy moved from Tel Aviv
television spectators around the world
watched as the two nations officials
gathered inside a large white tent a
metaphorical bubble that seemed to
protect them from the tragedy unfolding
50 miles away in Gaza there Israeli
soldiers opened fire on Palestinian
protesters those quotes are from me not
from her protesters killing at least
five dozen and wounding thousands more
Vox got even better with this buck said
Israelis are celebrating the US Embassy
move Palestinians are dying the Vox went
on just 60 miles away in the starkest
contrast imaginable Israeli soldiers
were firing on Palestinian protesters at
the Gaza border to protest the embassy
move demonstrations that were part of a
protest wait you notice how to keep
using the word protest wave ongoing
since March most of the protesters were
unarmed though some threw rocks and
Molotov cocktails but really won't talk
about that the Israeli military reported
at least one attempt to detonate a bomb
at the border during a demonstration by
the way this is what they keep using
they keep saying is the Israeli military
reported granted they reported the truth
we know they reported the truth but they
say okay yes some okay some of the
protesters were throwing rocks and
Molotov cocktails but the rest were
really peaceful
well done what about the ones that were
throwing bombs over Molotov cocktails
though it's surely that that's not
firing on peaceful protesters there were
40,000 Palestinian Arabs marching
throwing rocks and Molotov cocktails out
of all of the 40,000 marching
50 Arabs so far have been killed we've
seen huge videos of people throwing
Molotov cocktails run and detonate bombs
burning things to the ground so not good
we don't want to see bloodshed in that
area especially to protest something so
reasonable is moving an embassy to the
capital of a country but 50 out of
40,000 could have been a lot worse
a patrick Gailey from AFP news posted
this tweet is a tweet that's it was two
pictures it said left Jerusalem right
Gaza you know and they were all smiling
in Jerusalem and then there was all this
bloodshed in Gaza pictures taken at the
same time this afternoon Vox went on
said the contrast between the events is
jarring and it is jarring it is jory but
maybe not for the reason that Vox thinks
it's jarring because you're seeing two
cultures two different cultures
Mitt Romney talked about this in 2012
the difference between the Palestinian
Arab culture and the Israeli Jewish
culture and he got pilloried for this
because they said it was his lamo phobic
or whatever made-up word they decided to
use against Mitt Romney the these are
jarring pictures because they're
different cultures and you see what sort
of societies these two different
cultures produce a peaceful United
States Ally working democracy in Israel
and people throwing Molotov cocktails
are trying to detonate bombs and burning
tires in in the Arab territories and the
the Gaza Strip listen now CNN reports
this is the headline quote dozens of
Palestinians killed in Gaza clashes as
US Embassy opens now okay dozens of
Palestinians kill that's not good but it
doesn't it doesn't say how that were
they killed just randomly some Israelis
were walking down the street and said we
want to kill some Palestinian Arabs
today no they were they were killed but
they were killed because the Israelis
were acting in self-defense watch how
the media twists this in an absurdly
Orwellian way the article opens of it
says quote Palestinian officials accused
Israel of committing a horrific massacre
and called on the international
community to immediately intervene so
that's how it opens the first part is
Palestinians say it's a horrific
massacre look how awful this is right
only later in the article does it say
the military said the protesters threw
Molotov cocktails burned tires and
at Israeli soldiers positioned along the
fence now okay it says the military said
this we know that the protesters threw
the Molotov cocktails and burnt tires
how do we know CNN has video of it on
the same page as this article is written
here's the clip we see it very clearly
we see all the tires burning people
hurling these things over but CNN can
admit the reality so seeing it even
though it's right there and say don't
believe your lyin eyes that's just the
military said no you said well you
didn't say you just showed it with the
video by the way none of this coverage
is helping Palestinian Arabs
none of this fanning the flames that
these violent protests they've been
going on for two months now and the
mainstream media they're Fanning the
flames they say you deserve a country
you should have granted these are people
who are not living in a legitimate
nation-state people who in their own
elections their last election elected
Hamas a terrorist organization to govern
them they're Fanning the flames and
saying Jerusalem is not the capital of
Israel we know that Jerusalem was the
capital of Israel now contrasting this
also in Jerusalem today marks the
opening of the Guatemalan embassy there
they to Guatemala has moved the embassy
two days after the United States pretty
interesting because Guatemala is also
the second country to recognize Israel
in 1948 and the the lesson we can take
here is that other countries are
following American moral leadership
there were a lot of embassies in
Jerusalem before 1980 in 1980 the UN
Security Council denounced Israel and
they called on countries to move their
embassies to Tel Aviv but the u.s. today
still possesses moral leadership we
don't need to tiptoe around terrorists
people will follow us if we lead in 2006
the Palestinian people that imaginary
country elected Hamas we do not need to
pretend that there is equal moral
footing here we don't need to pretend
that there's equal moral footing between
the leaders of Hamas and between the
duly elected prime minister of a country
a successful functioning
amok recei in the Middle East the
leaders of Hamas and Bibi Netanyahu not
true the United States can lead people
can follow or they can fall in line
we don't need multinational open borders
world Federation's to accomplish these
things in fact very often there's those
institutions hamper a progress in hamper
security it is amazing even today where
nationalism is a bad word it's amazing
how well the nation-state still works
that product of the Westphalian system
of the world order it still works very
very well on that point let's bring on
our guest dr. Ihram hassan ii is an
israeli philosopher bible scholar and
political theorist president of the
Herzl institute in jerusalem and the
author of the forthcoming book the
virtue of nationalism dr. hassan ii
thank you so much for being here great
to have you
so dr. hassan ii you're a you're a bona
fide Jerusalem resident what is the
significance just from your own
perspective for Israeli citizens of
having the United States recognized
Jerusalem as the capital of Israel it's
huge it's its historical it's a it's a
massive thing I mean the United States
as you were saying the United States
still possesses immense moral leadership
but but more important than that maybe
even is is it possesses immense power
and it's Israel still a small country
and I thank God it's growing it's
probably in a better position now than
it's been at any point since its
founding but when when the entire world
when when all of Europe and all of all
of Asia in America's is beating on you
and saying you're an occupier in your
own capital look that's it that's an
extremely difficult this extremely
difficult in Israel are our grateful - I
were at the at the reception for the
moving of the embassy on Monday night I
I can't tell you people were crying it
was unbelievably moving to have this
vote of confidence and a faith from from
the the greatest power on earth it's
incredibly important to us and it's
amazing how long it took it's a
how murky politicians have been able to
make this clear moral issue right
there's a reason that all of these
presidential candidates over time have
promised we're going to move the embassy
to Jerusalem Jerusalem's the capital of
Israel and then they don't do it they
say oh well you know it's complicated I
don't know and this guy comes in and he
says no this is the capital the
nation-state is a legitimate construct
and you you this brings us to a second
point you've written extensively
recently an excellent articles I'm a
huge fan of your writing criticizing
what we could call the New World Order
the open borders the European Union the
World Federation type liberalism and
you've been defending what I'll call the
old New World Order which is to say
nationalism the Westphalian system in a
in a word in a phrase what is so great
about nationalism nationalism is is as
you know a biblical a biblical vision
the idea that the people's should be
free what does it mean for a people to
be free it means today we use words like
sovereignty we've got all these
technical terms but but in in Hebrew
Scripture the vision of the prophets is
that Israel and at other nations will
have borders they'll govern themselves
and they'll be independent of the
Egyptian Empire the Babylonia Empire the
Assyrian Empire all these empires had
had a clear vision for how to bring
peace to the world by conquering it and
scripture the philosophy of the Hebrew
Bible is in fact this the this idea that
justice depends on on people's being
able to be free that's such an important
point because we here now we think of
the nation-state as this modern
construct because the world order is
being totally divided into apparent
nation-states that comes relatively in
the modern era but the idea of the
nation is certainly not a modern concept
it's you're right it comes it comes
relatively in the modern okay I mean
there are harbingers in in medieval
Catholicism but but the big push is is
definitely with Protestantism
Protestantism reads Hebrew Scripture in
some respects with new eyes and says
this
this is a this is a road map to how to
bring justice to our world right that's
exactly right and that point is
frequently lost another point that is
frequently lost and it's why I really
like your writing I've recently been
buffing up again on my Edmund Burke and
Michael Oakshott and some of those
conservative writers I saw that you
tweeted out my Glock shot I did I did I
I think you're the only person probably
who appreciated that you know many of us
but this is this is a real problem
because we frequently hear you know even
on the right
that conservatives they're they're
actually classical liberals those are
the same thing
Bill Kristol said this recently as I
think you noted you said cuz he said
conservatives should rebrand as liberals
were the real liberals but you point out
that there is a difference what is the
difference between conservative thought
and classical liberalism something right
I just want to add on on the point
you're making some at some point in the
last generation you start to do we've
reached this point where you talk to
somebody who's a conservative and you
say well can you tell me what what what
you stand for and what it takes them
about seven seconds before before they
start telling you how liberal they are
and I know seriously so I I believe in
freedom I believe in freedom of speech I
believe in limited government and I
believe in free markets and maybe maybe
freedom of immigrant immigration and I'm
like okay what I believe in those things
those are good things but what makes you
conservative it's like oh no no
conservatism is is liberalism this is
this is no this is this is like a
monstrous confusion all right I don't
want to just play semantical games
because you know playing words with with
labels but but there really are two
extremely different historical world
views that clashed over many many
centuries and and what's happened is
that in in the conservative movement
movement today there's kind of like this
you know you're just not supposed to
talk about you know that I don't know if
they're talking about paleo or this or
that or Russell Kirk it's just look it's
just not that long ago we're talking
about I was in college in the 1980s
Ronald Reagan was president the Margaret
Thatcher was prime minister in in in the
UK
and we we had you know like a
conservative movement we founded a
conservative magazine Irving Kristol had
this organization that inducted us into
the conservative movement and we knew
what we we stood for of course we were
for free markets but the krystal krystal
talk taught us Irving Kristol that
conservatism was built on three things
right I'm quoting on religion on
nationalism and on economic growth and
he emphasized repeatedly not just him
does everybody understood this that the
freedom is it is it is a wonderful thing
but it's also it's also corrosive it's
it's it opens up a space but it's also
corrosive anybody who raises children
knows you can't just give them endless
freedom you can't there have to be
boundaries and those boundaries are
drawn by religious tradition national
traditions to be a conservative is
always been to balance those things and
the Anglo American conservative
tradition is a ISM is a balancing a
common-sense balancing among nationalism
and religion and all of these crucial
freedoms that this this tradition is has
developed so there are liberals today
fine you want to be liberal go ahead I
respect that time I know lots of really
bright people are liberals but do we
have a right to be a conservative too I
really think that's a question today
that that is such a good point because
you see these writers even relatively
recent writers like Russell Kirk for
instance and they sort of pushed to the
side so now it's very cool and to be on
the left and it's even sort of cool to
say I'm no longer on the left but I'm a
classical liberal I did okay that's okay
but the minute you bring up Edmund Burke
or Russell Kirk or a Oakshott or the
those guys they say oh no they've been
written out that's no no no we're
although I have yeah they've been
written out or or I have I have an
alternative for you a lot of people
saying these days
no you'll hear it in the movement you'll
hear this Oh Burke Burke grew out of
John Locke Burke grew out of liberalism
or Burke believed in freedom and freedom
is liberalism so so Burke is really just
a liberal I can't tell you how many
times I've heard this I don't know it's
like invasion of the Body Snatchers what
do you know what are you talking about
whether it's I wonder
it comes because you know conservatives
we tend to be this very sort of timid in
modern political conservatism
self-flagellating so no I'm really a
liberal know all of my forebears are
really liberal the students and this
gets to another historical misconception
which you've written about very well
everyone today all you see everywhere is
just how great the Enlightenment was
there's that Steven Pinker book about
how great the Enlightenment was every
every good thing in history had to come
from the Enlightenment and everything
before that were in the big bad old
times and you write and say that the
Enlightenment wasn't really all that
great but didn't you know these people
who who extol the virtues of the
Enlightenment they say it gave us modern
science modern medicine technology
modern philosophy Liberty political
order what do you say I say well look
these are sincere people I don't I don't
mean to challenge no I really like and
respect Steve Pinker as a scientist and
as a person and and Jonah Goldberg and
there's all sorts of people pushing this
Enlightenment line now and I really just
unfortunately think that that that what
it's kind of a historical sleight of
hand what they do is is they they take
all of these these great scientific
figures like like Newton or Boyle or
Harvey you know they say oh look they
were free thinkers therefore they were
liberals and there isn't it I mean there
isn't even at like a shred of truth to
this but it's just it's just false that
there were no open-minded creative
people all through history and a modern
science and medicine was was created by
those people but it doesn't mean that
they were liberals that that plenty of
opportunity to adopt fundamental
Enlightenment principles and declare
them and they they didn't because they
were 100 another of conservative right
so what what what are Enlightenment
principles let me would quickly name
name name them I think everybody knows
them but it's worth naming them
enlightenment means number one all human
beings are born free born perfectly free
Locke says and perfectly equal whatever
exactly that means they're perfectly
free and perfectly equal from birth
number two number two you
you don't receive you don't take on any
moral obligation unless you've freely
chosen it unless you've consented to it
okay and number three every human being
all through history has had the power of
reason that if they only exercised it
Locke says if they only exercised it
they would all come to the same answer
about what the what the exactly right
Constitution is so it's actually this
this extremely rigid set of of axioms
and that's not the same thing as science
that's not the same thing as modern
medicine it's not even the same thing as
the American Constitution but what it is
is the foundation for dogmatic
doctrinaire liberalism of the kind that
brings people to say well really we
don't need any of the traditions that
were handed down by our forefathers we
don't need biblical tradition we don't
need the national state we don't need
religion we don't need God we don't even
need the traditional family because I've
got reason and I can take on moral
obligation according to my consent and
John Locke told me so I don't need
anybody else that's a different yeah
yeah that's absolutely right you you can
look at all of those premises and say no
I don't remember being born perfectly
free without any obligations to family
or culture institutions and and now
there seems to be this big battle waging
there was this big burst of nationalism
the brexit the election of Donald Trump
in many ways and it's so funny to read
as you said earlier
Erving crystals words that the three
pillars of modern conservatism or
religion nationalism and economic growth
do you think that do you not to you know
ask you to make predictions you're not
Nostradamus exactly but as you look
around the political scene are we moving
in the right direction or is this just a
random blip a random little resurgence
of religion and nationalism and good
economic growth for the last year and or
are we inevitably going to fall back
into liberal malaise look all the forces
[Music]
all the forces of we as you know the the
the forces are not in the good direction
liberalism as distinct from the old
conservative American or British
religious nationalist tradition of
freedom let's just arbitrarily say that
since since World War two
what what we're calling liberalism is
kind of pushed the push the old
conservative tradition they used to call
Republican in America the old Republican
tradition is pushed to decide and we've
had pretty much 70 years I think you
could say of dismantling any kind of
public commitment one one piece after
another to religious tradition first to
the family then to the national state
and we're at this point that we've
reached a point where if if you go to an
excellent University and you want to
study conservative thought you basically
can't find somebody to teach it to you
right I'm including and I'm including
the token Republicans that some call the
college campuses have because they'll
tell you well here I'm going to teach
you conservatism here let's let's study
liberalism so that it could no seriously
worth up at the point where people don't
even know they don't even know that they
don't know what the old conservative
tradition was so if you add that to you
know the overwhelming liberalism or
further left in in the media and
Hollywood mean the entire public spheres
is flooded with anything but
conservatism so people who complain you
know a brexit brexit isn't pretty it's
not led by the right people you know the
trunk movement it's not pretty it's not
led by the right people maybe they have
you know maybe maybe they have a point
maybe I mean maybe if you let it it
would look a little bit more rugged I
don't or not but but guess what you
didn't lead it I didn't lead it right so
it was it was left to people who are
that they're not the educated you know
the most educated they're not the most
power
they're not they're not the people who
you know went to Ivy League schools like
some of us did and you know studied you
know exactly how you're supposed to
speak and exactly what you're supposed
to say and not only that but they kind
of look they're kind of sick and tired
of all of that right and and I
understand that I really do I love that
I get that I love that point that you
know they say oh it shouldn't be that
guy oh it should be better if it were
this guy leading oh it but they aren't
we have what we have the brexit was led
by the people it was led by truck of the
Trump movement is led by Donald Trump
and he doesn't hold his short and a
glass in the correct way but he seems to
be doing something that is distinct and
different and hopeful from what we've
seen recently I I agree with that but
and I'd add he's he and the brexit ears
they they've opened up a space for other
people
all right maybe if you want to step
forward and now and and describe and
intellectually articulated conservatism
that harkens back to the into the to the
great anglo-american tradition you
you're free to do that the the space is
open wide to do that except for the fact
I mean we'll see when this book on
nationalism appears whether people are
gonna will be willing to talk about it
because you know I do hear I'm bringing
all the footnotes I'm following all the
conventions I'm not gonna say anything
that's that's the wrong thing to say
let's see if people guys should put up
with it I write I don't know if they can
i really i really don't know we might be
you you asked what's gonna what's gonna
happen well I I definitely don't know
but when I when I when I look at the
field I just think people are are are so
as people who are my historic friends
even in the conservative movement not
just not not just Democrats Republicans
and in Britain it's the same thing
people are so afraid and they're so
angry and they're so upset that I mean
you can barely talk to them about
anything so I you you guys States you
stand for reason so I want a reason and
they're like shut up you know you you're
you're trying to reason but not about
that because it's not liberalism
and I'm like I never said I was a
liberal I never did yeah you made me say
yeah you want me to say that you want me
to say I'm a liberal so I can be part of
your show but but I was never a liberal
all right and I'm not I was never a
fascist either I'm a conservative how
can you deal with that I love that there
is such a thing I love that point it's
just an open conservative articulating
conservative thought and saying I'm not
part you can't put me into this box
there is a tradition it's attrition and
that isn't taught and there might be a
glimmer of hope you know there's
obviously it might be part of the
conservative disposition to say things
aren't looking great you know best days
are behind us but and maybe there's a
glimmer of hope and worst case then the
conservative point of view is right
dr. Hasani thank you so much is such a
such a good talk so good to talk to you
I've taken up way too much of your time
and we'll have to have you back when the
book comes out I love that thank you so
much for your time thank you
Yoram Hasani how smart is that guy I
love nobody is saying what he is saying
and it's so important to conservatives
okay I got to say goodbye to Facebook
and YouTube we're running late as it is
but be sure to tune in to that MiraCosta
high school speech we're gonna get that
up tomorrow and you'll be really
impressed with these kids
maybe if dr. Hasani sees it he'll have
some more hope for the future right now
go to daily wire.com
do it do it walk run don't walk we thank
you for everybody who's already there
you helped keep the lights on really
appreciate that
keep khofifah in my cup I've obviously
overdone it a little on the cafe in the
last few days if you're on Facebook or
YouTube you got to go over there right
now why what do you get you get me at
the end of flaming sure you get the Ben
Shapiro show you test questions in the
conversation next up is the big boss
himself ben shapiro none of that matters
this is the really special this is a
religious vintage this could be used as
the wine of ritual the wine of religious
observance because this is the special
Embassy in Jerusalem vintage of leftist
tiers and it's really it's salty they're
always salty but these are sweet these
are sweet as well it they're so good
go over to the onlywire come get your
leftist ears tumblr we'll be right back
I could talk to dr. Hasani all day I
could go on with that guy for three
hours his perspective is so important
for conservatives it's totally
overlooked these days on both the left
and the right I really urge everybody to
go out and read his articles as op-eds
and his books before we get to this day
in history we'll just mention the state
history a little bit I have to say I
gave this talk at the high school today
on the virtues of gun ownership and it
was really brave of the school to invite
me because now it the whole thing at
high schools is if you support the
Second Amendment you want to kill kids
that's the narrative by the mainstream
media as I was speaking at this high
school a news report broke unfortunately
I didn't get it on my phone that a
police officer at Dixon high school was
able to shoot and wound a student who
started to open fire today so an old
student shows up a graduated student
shows up to graduation practice 19 year
old former student and just starts
firing several shots outside the gym
fortunately they had an armed police
officer there and that cop took him out
and it gets even better because he
didn't even kill the kid he shot the
student the student was then taken to
the hospital with non-life threatening
injuries and he will hopefully face
trial and have to pay for what he did
this could have been a massacre this
could have been an absolute disaster if
that school were a gun-free zone but
that school isn't a gun-free zone
because a cop had a gun there and the
cop wasn't a coward like the Broward
County Sheriff's Office the cop went out
there and he started shooting and he
saved a lot of lives
this is tremendous stuff and it's a
perfect articulation of one of the great
reasons to have our Second Amendment and
to preserve our right to keep and bear
arms because ultimately it's about
preserving Liberty from tyranny but it's
also about preserving our life and
liberty in very particular circumstances
at a high school at what could have been
a gun-free zone get out there save a lot
of lives really really good stuff and it
really underscores why we need to keep
our guns you can see the rest of the
speech tomorrow on this day in history I
want to get to this day in history
because there the it's deja vu all over
again those people who don't learn from
the past they're bound to repeat it it
seems like what does the other quote
history repeats itself
tragedy second is force well we're
seeing the forest with a little rocket
man right now because on this day in
history in 1960 American negotiations
with a crazed communist dictator broke
down after an American military exercise
ticked off the Red Menace this is
exactly what is happening today deja vu
all over again on May 1st 1960 Soviets
took down a u2 US spy plane so
Khrushchev the head of the Soviet Union
tore into Eisenhower they were at a
summit meeting in Paris and he tears
into him and let me tell you something
nobody talks to Eisenhower that way no
way it totally doomed the summit because
they were able to shoot down the spy
plane at first
Eisenhower denied that the u2 plane was
being used to spy he said oh that metal
thing know that that obvious spy plane
oh that's a weather plane we just wanted
to figure out the weather in Moscow
we're really nervous and we hope you
guys didn't get too much rain and but
what he didn't realize is the Soviets
have captured the plane and the pilot
Gary Frances Powers who admitted what
was going on ultimately President
Eisenhower had to admit it this was
followed then by another public
dressing-down
by Khrushchev and the negotiations were
off the table for a while we're seeing
hints of this right now but we're seeing
it as farce we're not seeing his tragedy
we're seeing it as farce anything
involving little rocket man is usually a
farce a little rocket man over in Korea
is threatening to cancel the
long-promised peace talks that are
supposed to take place June 15th I
believe in Singapore he says you're the
u.s. and South Korea they're conducting
regular military exercises and I don't
like it they have to call it off or
we're gonna cancel the summit this is
the big wrench in the peace talks Sarah
Sanders the greatest press secretary
ever she's so good she handled this
perfectly she said quote if they want to
meet will be ready if they don't that's
okay too this is something that we fully
expected and of course they expected it
of course we knew that this crazed
little dictator was gonna try to throw a
wrench in things at the end and try to
trick us and get a leg up on the United
States that's fine they can do it we
don't need this we don't actually need
these peace talks Donald Trump doesn't
need these peace talks he doesn't you
know Barack Obama had absolutely
legacy he knew that his legacy was gonna
be erased by the end of his presidency
so he pushed for that Iran deal so hard
because he needed something he needed
that legacy he was dead even if it means
we fly airplanes full of cash and free
up sanctions and give them a path to a
nuclear weapon even if it means all that
just give me a legacy give me a deal
Trump doesn't need that he's already got
a lot of accomplishments and we're not
gonna make a bad deal we're not gonna
say okay we're gonna make Iran deal part
two no way absolutely not because by the
way the Barack Obama doesn't have the
Iran deal now anyway he's just as zero
legacy he's just like a gaping hole in
presidential history just don't have a
queue mother just light just you know
goes in it goes from Clinton to Bush to
something that used to be here and then
to trump so Donald Trump doesn't need it
if Kim jong-un is serious about
canceling the talks that's fine we're no
worse off than we were before we have a
few options we can either continue to
continue to use strategic patience or we
can go in and take him out take care of
him
and that will assess various risks to
Seoul that we'll assess various military
risk that's exactly where we were before
these peace talks or Kim jong-un could
take the only step that's in front of
him which is to try to engage the United
States but he's he's not gonna get one
over on them on the American the the
administration that's currently in
charge he might have gotten one over on
the Obama administration he isn't gonna
get one over on John Bolton and Mike
Pompeo and Donald Trump it just isn't
going to happen so we'll see what
happens here we won the Cold War the
peace trucks broke down in 1960 we won
the Cold War it's a it's okay might take
a little longer but American resolve
will not certainly should not crack here
and I think it will not crack because
we've seen this coming out of the White
House we've seen wonderful strength from
Sarah Sanders Pompeyo Bolton and Trump I
hope we continue to see that and I think
we will this is very good news that
glimmer of hope that the generally sort
of dour conservative disposition is
looking at good things all around okay
this is our show that's our whole show
on on nationalism on the nation-state
maybe we'll end up taking a nation state
away from North Korea we'll see in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Nolt show check out that speech
that's coming up tomorrow I will see you
then
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you